[Music]
good morning everyone
thanks for joining us on day three of
i/o to talk about thread and Google
cloud my name is Ken Barnes I'm a
product manager on Google Cloud IOT core
and I'm Jonathan Hui principal software
engineer at Google Nest and VP of
technology for the thread group so we're
super excited about this session today
and to tell you a little bit about
things that are happening in thread and
IOT core before we get started can we
just see maybe show of hands how many of
you here have heard about thread before
okay most one yeah pretty good Jonathan
and what about IOT core or use Google
Cloud in any way before also pretty good
okay so if you haven't heard about them
don't worry we're gonna give a little
brief intro when we get started here if
you have I think we have a really really
exciting session today because we are
going to be demoing for the first time
MQTT and tcp over a thread network all
the way up to the cloud and we're also
going to be showing co-op communication
to IOT core but before we get started I
want to talk a little bit about what are
requirements for the device that we're
gonna build and demo today are and how
they differ from maybe some of the
current IOT devices whether they be
smart home or commercial buildings that
are on the market so for the devices
we're gonna build today we want them to
be very very low-power so this means not
just having long battery life but also
being able to work on very very small
batteries for long amounts of time next
we want no proprietary hubs or gateways
we don't want to have proprietary
application layers or require users to
install new hardware for every single
device that they buy and finally we want
I P all the way to the edge so we want
our devices to work with the existing
internet standards and protocols that we
know are secure and are comfortable
working with but before we get into how
we're going to do that I want to talk
about the state of wireless products
and I think this is true whether you're
talking about smart home smart buildings
industrial wireless products I think it
really runs the gamut so today we have a
lot of devices that are using Wi-Fi
using 802 dot 11 and this works great
for many classes of devices if you have
a camera a smartphone or laptop
something where you can recharge the
battery you need to use a lot of
bandwidth Wi-Fi is great but for devices
that need to be very low-power Wi-Fi
isn't as good you need to either be able
to recharge the device frequently like
your laptop or phone or you need to do a
lot of tricks to end up making it be
very low-power over time the other issue
with Wi-Fi is when you start having lots
of nodes so especially for your average
consumers home wireless setup if you
want to connect every single light bulb
or light switch in your house you're
gonna have an issue doing that with your
traditional router and still have the
rest of your devices work so we know
that even though there's a lot of good
Wi-Fi infrastructure in place it's
probably not the technology we want to
use to build our next generation
wireless and IOT products so I know what
a lot of you might be thinking well
there are good solutions out there for
this today we have Bluetooth we have
ZigBee we have z-wave a number of
wireless technologies that will help us
build lower bandwidth but lower power
consumption and also scale to large
numbers of nodes in small spaces
however while these do address a number
of the issues that we're looking for if
they have one critical fallback and
that's that they need lots of these IOT
gateways so they since they depend on
their own radio technologies usually
proprietary application layers and
tightly linked application backends you
can end up in situations where if you
have multiple products from multiple
vendors or even in some cases multiple
products from the same vendor where you
end up with a whole host of these
devices connected to your router at home
or it can be even worse in industrial or
commercial IOT settings and while this
does work from a technical perspective I
think it hurts user adoption in a couple
ways one is it drives up costs if you
need to sell a gateway with the first
light bulb that your customer buys or
the first whatever your product may be
you're probably more than doubling the
cost for that very first entry point
next is it creates confusing user setup
experiences nobody wants to have a lot
of these or go through having to learn
the differences between setting up a
Wi-Fi device versus a Bluetooth device
versus a sigma device and finally and I
think what the largest problem is is it
encourages silos so the manufacturers of
these gateways want every product to
work with their ecosystem and so we end
up with silos of functionality as
opposed to real Network interoperability
like we want to build so I think these
are some real problems but luckily were
pretty close to having a solution to
help with it so we were facing these
exact problems that Callum was talking
about at best where we wanted to build
products for the connected home where we
were keeping users not only comfortable
but also safe and secure we wanted to
build solutions where our devices could
communicate securely with each other to
cloud services and see users via their
mobile devices we also wanted to have
those devices to be very low power
because we wanted those devices to last
for years on very small batteries but as
we evaluated existing communication
technologies we could not find a single
technology that satisfied our
requirements so in 2014 nest along with
a number of other companies founded the
thread group the thread group is a
nonprofit organization with more than
100 member companies from around the
world and the thread group is
responsible for defining and maintaining
the thread protocol specification it
serves as a market education group for
promoting the use of thread in connected
products and it ensures a great user
experience
through a rigorous and meaningful
product certification program so in
summary the threat protocol is an open
IP based low-power secure mesh
networking technology for connecting IOT
devices it supports the same IP
technology that drives every internet
connected device but is designed to
support very low-power applications
including devices that operate on coin
cell batteries now for the radio thread
users I Tripoli a two 2.15 dot four it's
the same radio that's been used in
ZigBee for fifteen years using an
existing widely deployed radio allows
thread products to achieve fast time to
market as well as leverage existing
economies of scale to achieve low-cost
solutions now with the network layer
thread uses existing IETF standards for
supporting the Internet Protocol version
6 or ipv6 over a two 2.15 dot four
radios a technology called 6lowpan now
thread support for the Internet Protocol
is a key differentiator and most
existing technologies do not support IP
so why is IP so powerful well first it
means that we can build solutions that
utilize a number of link technologies
including Wi-Fi cellular and thread and
have all of those devices communicating
with a common single application layer
end-to-end without needing to build and
maintain application protocol gateways
and at the same time it means we could
have a single network that can support
multiple applications simultaneously IP
makes it easy to deploy new applications
and it was a key reason for the success
of the internet and thread extends that
benefit to low-power devices and
specifically for this session it means
that we can build battery powered
devices that communicate securely
end-to-end with Google Cloud IOT core
without any application layer in between
ok so now we've seen how we are going to
use thread as the radio technology
to build these products and we also know
that thread is going to give us a
underline IP layer link which means we
can use just about any cloud back-end
that we want to to connect these
products and leverage data from them or
interact with them but let's talk about
first what we need to think about when
we choose a cloud product or choose a
cloud to use there are a lot of options
out there and I think a lot of them will
probably satisfy what we're going to do
today but there are two big things that
you want to think about first is
security and the second is scale so
security is always important in IOT it's
a very often written about topic I'm
sure I don't need to tell people at i/o
about all of the high profile leaks that
have happened or botnet attacks that
have happened but what is going to drive
more security in IOT I think starts with
identity and having a strong underlying
identity for our products so we want to
make sure that whatever we choose is
going to allow us to put a
cryptographically strong and unique
identity on the boards that we're gonna
use in the demo today an X is scale and
I think there's a few things to think
about when you are thinking about scale
in the context of IOT one is we are
thinking about large numbers of devices
so over time we think there might be you
know millions or tens of millions of
devices that we might sell into market
and need to connect to this cloud so we
need a solution that we know can scale
up to very large numbers of devices but
we should also realize that at the very
beginning your IOT deployment or
solution might be just like ours is on
stage where you have just one or two
devices and for this reason you want
whatever you choose to scale from an
economic perspective when you still have
just a few devices in market so to do
this today we're going to use Google
Cloud IOT core IOT core is Google clouds
managed service for connecting IOT
devices to the Google cloud network it
provides
two important things that we're going to
show today so first is device identity
provides a mechanism for distributing
key based identities to devices so every
device will end up with its own unique
private key as well as the corresponding
public key trusted in IOT core these
keys can be used in a couple different
ways to connect and authenticate to the
system and jonathan is going to talk
more about that later the other thing it
offers is a protocol bridge and support
for common I owe t protocols like MQTT
and HTTP and what this protocol bridge
is completely serverless
and will scale with our application so
it's easy to connect just a few devices
to it and will only have to pay for
those cut the bandwidth used by those
couple devices but it will also easily
scale up to hundreds of thousands or
millions of devices deployed all over
the globe without us having to change
any code or deal with managing the
backend
but connecting the devices to the cloud
isn't the whole story we need to
actually communicate back to the devices
or leverage the data that they're
sending to us if we want to build an
actually useful application and luckily
Google cloud can help with this - so
we're gonna today try to leverage all
serverless tools that will scale
elastically with your application the
same way that I just talked about IOT
core doing so the first thing that we're
going to use a Google cloud pub/sub so
all data sent from IOT devices into IOT
core end up as a message on a cloud
pub/sub topic pub/sub if you're not
familiar with it is a scaleable message
bus to build event-driven server lists
or micro service applications so you'll
never have to worry about scaling for
Peaks or dealing with losing data the
next thing we're going to use is cloud
functions so a cloud function is a small
snippet of code that can be written in a
few different languages that are
supported right now and it allows you to
do event-driven development so this
function can fire every time an event
occurs or at a regular interval in this
case we're going to use it to process
each message in each event that comes
into our pub/sub stream this will make
it easy to again scale our application
but also build it and finally we're
going to use cloud fire store the fire
store is a flexible no sequel database
hosted and managed by Google Cloud and
you'll see the query system and
real-time update nature will make it
easy for us to build this application
but also in the future build a mobile
application or other application that
leverages that data Google Cloud has
dozens of other services that can help
with building your application but these
are the few that we're going to use for
the demo today all right so let's get to
some of the fun stuff and actually show
you how we can build some of it now as
mentioned thread support for IP makes it
possible for a thread device to
communicate securely and end-to-end with
IOT core in the middle there is a thread
border router that's responsible for
forwarding packets between the thread
network and the public Internet and note
that the thread border router simply
Ford's IP packets at the network layer
and does not need to implement any
application layer logic or proxy in fact
the thread border router has no
knowledge of MQTT or HTTP making it easy
to deploy new applications without
having to update or maintain application
layer proxies in between now three years
ago here at i/o we launched the open
thread project open thread is an open
source implementation of thread and it
is the same implementation that's used
in nest products including the nest hub
max that was announced here at i/o the
open thread project is hosted on github
and licensed under BSD three and it's
seen widespread adoption open thread has
been ported to more than 10 different
802 dot 15.4 radios and you can find
example drivers for each of those in
github now in today's demo we'll use the
Nordic NRF 50 to 840 system-on-chip we
actually brought a few of those here
with us today for use in our demo so
let's take a look at them on stage
you'll see a couple dev boards on the
right
and then a USB dongle attached to a
Raspberry Pi on the left these at the
NRF 50 to 840 is built around a 32-bit
ARM Cortex m4 but 256 K of RAM 1 mega
flash and they're really intended for
low-power low-cost applications and
these dev boards are publicly available
which means you can go home and play
with and replicate everything we've done
on stage today alright so let's get back
to the slides alright so let's get
started with mqtt now for those of you
that don't know MQTT stands for message
queuing telemetry transport and is one
of the most popular transport protocols
used in IOT applications today MQTT
implements a published subscribe model
on top of tcp/ip now in this example
we'll walk through how to build an mqtt
over thread endpoint that communicates
securely and to end with IOT core we
will leverage third-party software for
networking
we'll use lightweight IP or l web
allowing us to leverage application
frameworks that have already been built
on top of l WIPP including MQTT for
security this example leverages embed
TLS and a jot c library for security and
for the artists will use free artists
well let's walk through some of the code
so here's the main control loop that
runs on the thread device it's pretty
simple
it starts by establishing an MQTT
session - IOT core and then it sits in a
while loop publishing telemetry events
every two seconds so let's dive into the
connect method first the first step is
to specify the mqtt connection
parameters MQTT uses TLS for transport
layer security so we have to set up the
private key and certificates for use for
TLS we also need to specify other
mqtt parameters such as the client ID
and keepalive values now at the bottom
the device must also prepare a JSON web
token
let's take a look closer look at what
that JSON web token is
now as Callum mentioned IOT core
provides a device identity system a JSON
web token or jot is a compact URL safe
means of presenting representing claims
and is used for device authentication
with IOT core Ajanta is composed of
three sections a header a payload that
contains a claim set in a signature the
header and payload are JSON objects and
the header consists of two fields that
indicate the signing algorithm and the
type of the token the example here uses
RSA but IOT core also supports elliptic
curve now the payload contains a set of
claims that is signed using asymmetric
keys IOT core requires three claims the
issued at which is the timestamp at when
the token was created the expiration
that is the timestamp when the token
stops becoming valid an audience that
contains the cloud project ID where the
device is registered and then finally
the signature contains a cryptographic
signature of the concatenated header and
payloads
so in CRO encode creating a John looks
like this it leverages the John Hsu
library and we first create the object
then set the signing algorithm for the
jobs we add the issued at expiration and
audience claims and finally we call jot
encode stir which generates the
signature and writes it out in the
proper encoding so that's how we
generate a client's authentication
material for IOT core and more generally
the MQTT connection parameters the next
step is to perform a dns lookup for the
MQTT endpoint in this case mqtt google
api is calm now with the IP address for
the mqtt endpoint we can then initiate
an mqtt connection so that was connected
pretty simple so now let's take a look
at how to publish telemetry events using
MQTT in this example the telemetry
events are really simple temperature
the first step is to format the payload
in this case using JSON and then we call
mqtt publish with the payload and
specify an mqtt topic of slash device's
slash MQTT - device slash events MQTT -
device specifies the device ID and
events indicates that this is a
telemetry event that's it pretty simple
so now let's take a look at what this
look how this works in a live demo in
this demo we'll be using a Nordic dev
board as the MQTT endpoint the Nordic
dev board communicates securely end to
end with IOT cores MQTT bridge now the
thread border router will use a
Raspberry Pi with the Nordic USB dongle
and for the cloud application will have
a simple cloud function that processes
telemetry events and saves them to a
fire store database so let's take a
quick look at the physical devices again
just just so the dev board in the middle
is is will be the one that we use for
the MQTT endpoint and that will
communicate wirelessly via the raspberry
pi and to end with IOT core so now let's
switch over to my laptop and show you
some live demos so first thing i'll do
is actually pull up on the cloud side
just kind of show you the cloud function
here so the cloud function listens for
the topic temperature events and each
time that it's triggered it simply
decodes the payload which includes the
temperature data and puts that into a
fire stored at abase it's a very simple
cloud function and then in our fire
store database here we have a collection
that's just for this demo and then we
have a document for the mqtt device
itself and of course we have some data
that you know set to zero for now now if
we go over here I have a console open to
a raspberry pi so as you know the
raspberry pi is the thread border router
if I do and I have config you'll see at
the bottom the WPA 0 interface you
the network interface that represents
the thread network as you can see the
thread network itself appears as a
standard linux network interface just
like Wi-Fi or Ethernet now what I'm
going to do next is start a TCP dump on
the WPS zero interface so we can kind of
see some traffic that's going over that
thread Network now what I have also
attached to my laptop is the mqtt
endpoint so I'll open a terminal there
and it has a very simple remember this
is an embedded device so it doesn't even
have you know a proper terminal but it
has a very simple CLI and I do IP a
turtle is this IP addresses of course
nothing's listed yet because it's not
connected so if I bring the interface up
and start thread the thread service and
wait a moment you'll see now that it has
IP addresses because it's now connected
to the thread network and has obtained
the unnecessary information to configure
those IP addresses and finally I'll
start the MQTT service go back over to
the TCP dump there first thing you'll
see is an NTP request response that's
the device itself synchronizing with
global time and then after some amount
of time you'll start to see TCP traffic
that TCP traffic is the mqtt session
itself of course we can't see the
payload because it's within a TLS
encrypted session but this is to show
you there's actual TCP traffic happening
you'll see messages have pop up about
every 2 seconds and you'll see the
actual data being presented here live
and every time it receives a new message
you'll see that field popping so that's
it
so that was our first demo demonstrating
mqtt talking end-to-end securely with
IOT core
all right awesome Jonathan yeah I
believe that is the first time publicly
that we've demoed any TCP protocol and
MQTT over a thread network so that's
pretty exciting going all the way to IOT
core and then up into our very simple
database application so that's really
great but MQTT and tcp are still require
a fair amount of power this would maybe
be good for a device which has mains
power is connected all the time but that
you still need a low latency
communication back down to like a light
switch or light bulb but now let's think
about a much more constrained device I
talked about at the beginning wanting to
be able to power a device on just a
small coin cell battery so let's talk
about using co-op with IOT core so if
you're not familiar with co-op it's the
constrained application protocol and
it's a specialized web transfer protocol
that's made for basically exactly what
we want to do very constrained devices
and using very small amounts of power
co-op is designed to be a lot like HTTP
and it implements the widely used rest
model so servers make resources
available under a URL and clients access
those resources using the familiar rest
methods like get put post delete co-op
was intentionally designed to resemble
HTTP to make it easier for developers to
build applications with it but there are
some differences so at the network layer
you can see it's exactly the same ipv4
or ipv6 and that's exactly what's going
to make it easy to use with our thread
network but the primary difference is on
the transport layer with co-op will be
using UDP as opposed to TCP and because
of that for transport layer security
we'll also need to use D TLS or data
Gramm transport layer security which is
specifically designed to function
similar to TLS and provide similar
levels of security for UDP connections
and finally at the top we'll use co-op
but from a developer standpoint this
should look mostly like accessing http
interfaces unfortunately IOT core
not natively support co-op but because
co-op and HTTP are so similar it's very
easy to build implement or use one
that's already out there
stateless co-op - HTTP proxies so in
this case what happens is we'll use the
proxy URI option in co-op an option and
co-op is basically the same as a header
in HTTP and we will include information
about the URI of the address that we
would like to access we would like the
proxy to access for us and what will
happen then is the proxy will initiate
and make the HTTP request receive the
response from the server and then return
the response as a co-op response which
is a little different than HTTP but this
allows the co-op endpoint to use a
restful HTTP service pretty much as if
it was accessing it directly but still
getting the benefits of low power design
and and co-op it's important to note
that the coffee HTTP proxy jonathan will
talk more about code availability later
but the one that we'll use in this demo
is available for you to go download and
run it's completely stateless so it
should scale very easily with any
application using coop and the IOT core
HTTP bridge so without further ado let's
get into it and then see it happen yeah
let's see how we can build a co-op
endpoint that communicates with IOT core
now as with the MQTT example thread
support for IP makes it possible to
communicate securely and to end but
compared to the MQTT example one
difference is the introduction of the
coop proxy that Callum was talking about
now it's just to remind everyone the
proxy provides pass-through
authentication passively to IOT core
relating device credentials directly to
IOT core and the proxy doesn't do
anything to validate it the incoming
co-op payload is converted to the
required format for IOT core HTTP bridge
and the responses from IOT cores HTTP
bridge will be returned to the client
with an appropriate co-op response code
now here's the Software Architect
you may note that the this appears much
simpler than our MQTT example this
example runs in bare mental environments
and does not include an artist this
example also does not include a
third-party IP stack and other
application frameworks the coop protocol
is actually used within thread itself so
this example can actually leverage the
same co-op implementation that's within
open thread so in short what makes this
example really attractive is the ability
to operate in very constrained devices
that have limited memory and code space
again the code has two high-level
functions the first is to establish a
secure connection and then followed by
publishing telemetry events via that
secure connection so let's take a look
at established in that secure connection
first for simplicity this example uses a
hard-coded IP address but we could have
done that using a DNS lookup as in the
mqtt example we also need a to setup the
security credentials for establishing
the secure session here we use a pre
shared key cipher suite finally we call
ot kept secure connect to establish the
D TLS session so let's take a look at
the coop HTTP proxy implementation in
this demo in this example the coop proxy
listens on a specific path slash GCP and
the proxy tra option includes the
request URI path that the co-op proxy
users when translating that request on
behalf of the coop endpoint and it
includes things like the project ID
device ID and the publish event action
so with co-op we use the post method to
publish telemetry events the first part
of generating the coop post request is
to set up the coop header this includes
specifying the path GCP and the coop
proxy your re option along with the
publish event sub path that indicates
that this is a telemetry event so let's
dive into that proxy or I option a
little more now first we format the
proxy URI path
that the coop proxy uses when
translating this request again including
things like the project ID registry ID
device ID and then we include the jot
which includes the claims that specify
the issue that expiration and audience
claims that we talked about earlier we
then pass that proxy or I string to job
create for encoding and signature
generation and once we have the jots we
add that to the coop header in the proxy
or I option so that was generating the
coop header with a proxy or I option now
let's take a look at the coop payload
itself again it's pretty simple here we
format the telemetry event data in JSON
format as we did in the MQTT example and
then we append that to the payload of
the coop message pretty simple so now
with a complete co-op request message we
can send that request to the co-op proxy
so now let's take a look at again how
this looks in action again we'll use a
Nordic dev board that's operates up this
coop endpoints and that Nordic dev board
communicates wirelessly again via the
raspberry pi serving us that spread
border router difference here is that
rather than communicating directly to
IOT core it is communicating with the
coop proxy the choir proxy then
stateless lis translates that message
into something that IOT core can
understand which is HTTP now in the
cloud side again we use the same exact
cloud function and fires to our database
as we did with the mq GG demo so let's
go back to my laptop so here it's the
same screen that I left it you can still
see the mqtt device still publishing
data every two seconds but I have
another document here which is for the
coop device itself and of course because
I haven't turned it on that data is
still set to zero now for if I move back
to the console real quick again TCP
traffic flowing through the thread
border router on the thread interface
and on the on the desk here if I pick it
up here's the coop endpoint it's a
Nordic dev board
and the difference here rather than
being plugged in just to show how low
power is this this def board actually is
powered off point cell battery right so
all I'm gonna do is turn the dev board
on you'll see some green LEDs hopefully
blinking and what you start to see here
is again an NTP message for this device
to get global time you start to see some
UDP traffic up in the console that's
that was the detail last session itself
being established and in this case it is
event triggered so if I push a button
here you'll see UDP messages and those
UDP messages actually are the coop
messages being transmitted by this
device through the thread border router
and if I switch back to the firestore
database the coop device information you
can see now that that counter value is
being updated each time I press the
button pretty cool so that was the coop
demo now what we've shown is to thread
devices talking through the same border
router using standard IP technology in
this case we are talking to the same
service and the same ultimate database
but the important thing to note here is
we could just as easily have been
talking to two completely different
backends these can be two devices from
two different vendors but there are up
or interoperating at the network level
and going through the same border router
without having to worry about or have
any knowledge of each other so I think
that pretty much wraps it up hopefully
this shows how you as developers can
think about and use thread and as border
routers become more prevalent you can
worry about just building your devices
and having them talk to your back-end
services wherever they might be hosted
using standard IP technologies so if you
want to see the tutorials and code they
have it posted for both the demos at
these links and if you have questions
Jonathan I will be right outside
afterwards so thanks very much
[Music]
you
[Music]